[Music]
let's go to la crosse wisconsin where
mark joins us mark how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking the call um
to the question
uh before my wife when i got married uh
it'll be 13 years in october congrats we
took the finance piece oh thank you
we had a choice between financial peace
or marriage classes
and i said financial physical marriage
classes we did both um anyhow um i
recently lost my job in july and
this past
october i got a different job and i've
been looking at you guys on podcast you
know the whole point of the question is
since we are married we have had
separate checking and savings account
and then a joint savings for tax refunds
and what not um
my question for you guys i recently
listened to
your podcast yesterday
and uh you know talk about combining
everything
um
and i asked her about it and she
really wasn't on board with it because
we've been doing it for so long and it's
not really broken so she's like why do
we need to fix anything it's not broken
so
my question for you just keep doing
things the way we have been um
there hasn't been any real financial
issues yeah
so
um
uh
pretty much we're almost dead free so
that's awesome congrats yeah you called
rachel can help you with this but i'm
just curious before she dives in here
why you called
asking if it's okay which tells me you
may or may not think it is okay or one
of you thinks it's okay and one of you
doesn't am i right or am i wrong um
i i just
i think it's relatively okay but listen
to you guys
and uh previous
podcast um you guys are like really
saying that
marriage is working well it's the best
ideas i got so you're kind of wondering
all right tell him rachel yeah and that
in that segment that was with john
deloney and myself yeah we talked about
a study um that we found from the
journal of
personality and social psychology and it
talked about how they did a study that
yeah when couples pull their money
together they actually experience
greater relational satisfaction or less
likely to break up
because here's the deal mark now could
the dollars and cents work with how
you're doing it
sure absolutely like i mean you it could
literally like you said nothing's been
broken it could work but in my what i
would argue is that it could be so much
better because the things that you guys
don't even know are there
and or the things that are not even
being talked about because you are
living in these separate with these
separate checking accounts that's the
stuff that you miss out on because there
is this level of kind of independence
i'm doing your my thing over there
you're doing yours but when you throw
everything together it's like a it's a
clash and a explosion in a good way
that makes you kind of rethink things in
a sense that like man
i she's gonna see that purchase or he's
gonna know that i went there and and not
that you're intentionally trying to hide
anything but there's just this level of
openness that's there
when you have your money together so my
thing would be
yeah it may be working okay
but how much better could it be because
it's going to force conversations that
you're not forced to have right now and
again not even just money conversations
like winston and i we go through our
week to talk about like okay so what
does our evenings look like because we
got to figure out are we picking up
chick-fil-a after the girls gymnastics
or am i cooking like what what's
happening and you end up talking about
the out to eat budget you end up talking
about what's going on in life and
calendars man this feels really busy
right now i know i'm exhausted i know i
i'm missing like you end up in all these
other conversations
that combining your account spring so
it's not just the tactical side of money
that you benefit from but it's the
relational side so that's what i would i
would push you guys on do you feel a
nudge mark to do it to do it differently
i know you heard us talk about it on the
podcast but
do you think it would bring like a level
of of richness that's not there right
now
um i feel like we can get really well
now um
like we're
the only debt we have is uh truck
payment and um we just talk about it
we're going to knock it out quick and
she's putting money each check and then
it comes directly out of my checking
account and we're just trying to
it's we communicate well to start with
but yeah
like you said i i get them to hold each
other accountable um
like for example our oldest daughter's
in softball so she went and got the
valley helmet then i went and got the
bag and
the fielding mask so like we're pretty
open with each other
about everything but um
i'm sorry i mean center
holding each other accountable you know
so yeah you feel like you are holding
each other accountable
um
i think we just trust each other yeah
let me tell you the flip side of this
because we get this call a lot on the
ramsay show
couples with separate accounts rachel
good people well-meaning people
and when you have separate accounts and
you're not really accountable so you
don't know what he has she has whatever
and we get the call we hit separate
accounts and my spouse ran up
tens and tens of thousands of dollars in
credit card debt and i just found out
about it
that temptation could hit anybody
i mean nobody's above that yes so
there's no judgment here i'm just saying
that's the reality of this when we have
separate accounts and then one person
goes well i kind of get to do whatever i
want to do in this yeah and then maybe
they get themselves in a hole yeah we
hear about gambling problems we hear
about spending problems we got a call
just last week uh
a a separate accounts
and the wife found out that the husband
had racked up nearly a hundred thousand
dollars in credit card over legal fees
for custody for a child from a previous
marriage she just found out about it
yeah
this is bone crushing kind of stuff and
i would say two and i would be curious
your thoughts on this can because i this
is how passionate i feel about it mark
is that you can go down like that road
what ken just described for sure happens
100
but what what even made me like
kind of like
cringe
is that their daughter plays softball
and she goes and buys part of the
equipment and he goes and buys the other
part dude i'm saying mark like like
there's just this level of a division
that you're like no no
no we're all supposed to we're all
supposed to go and buy the stuff and it
comes out and it's not a big deal it's
it's the dividing
roommate it's really
i want you to hear like a lot of
a lot of grace in this okay because i
get that it's working and it's almost
the same mindset when people use credit
cards like when i pay it off every month
but i pay it off every month but i pay
but you have no idea how much more
you're spending when you have don't have
the emotions attached to your checking
account you don't even know what
conversations you're missing out on mark
and the things that are dividing y'all
because you haven't even done it because
you haven't combined it yet rachel i
think you make an incredible
relationship point
and that is that we are joint we are a
team we're not roommates
i could think of example for example but
i'll tell you an example that you made
me think of so we have a daughter josie
who's 13 and she and her little friend
just decided they wanted to start a
bracelet business oh these beads yeah
and i came home the other night and
one of the first things in the door
stacy said hey i gotta let you know
josie came to me today she's all excited
about starting this little business so i
told her we would invest you know we
would buy the first supplies helped her
with pricing all that stuff so this was
a couple's moment where she was just
proud to say this is josie's idea i went
out and it was 40 bucks for all the
things yeah yeah it wasn't a
accountability issue but it was this
idea that it could have been shin guards
yes cleats right right you name the
other but it was like we had a fun
little conversation it was like that's
awesome yes yes and that's a joint
account we tell each other we can see
what we spend yeah there is you don't
even have to hold someone accountable
when you're just open well that's what i
was gonna say to the accountability
thing i i that even that term i think i
feel weird to people it's a little
overused too of like i'm gonna keep you
accountable where it's like no i'm
actually gonna just know what's going on
and we're like
married i can't spend something without
her knowing yes it's fantastic right so
that is built in but i don't feel like
uh
yes yes totally totally so yeah there's
it's a it's a real thing again study
after study another one you know that
one that we just talked about that came
out last week that yeah you just have a
greater level of satisfaction because
you you share everything and and john
delaney made the point and we laugh
about it because i'm like you share your
genetics in a child that's running
around in front of you so like if you
can share your bed if you can share your
refrigerator you share everything share
everything and the money piece it it may
not feel like a big deal because like
you feel like it's just it's on the
track and it's working but i'm gonna
push y'all mark i mean i would and i
would and i would see how your
relationship changes because your
marriage changes when you see yourself
one thousand percent as one totally
agree she's preaching and she's right